This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. What would you have done? It's one of the most enduring questions in psychology. If you were a German soldier in the 1940s, would you have followed orders? If you were a member of a Hutu militia group in 1994, would you have killed your Tutsi neighbors in the unfolding genocide in Rwanda? If you were a son or daughter of a slave-owning family in 18th century America, would you have spoken out against racial injustice?
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。你会怎么做？这是心理学中最经久不衰的问题之一。如果你是20世纪40年代的一名德国士兵，你会服从命令吗？如果你是1994年卢旺达胡图族民兵组织的一员，在罗安达正在发生的种族灭绝中，你会杀死你的图西族邻居吗？如果你是18世纪美国一个蓄奴家庭的儿子或女儿，你会站出来反对种族不公吗？
What would you have done? The question is compelling, because while we all like to think we would have done the brave thing, the right thing, many of us have the sneaking suspicion we might not. We fear that we might have fallen in line like everyone else and done what we were told to do. Today on the show, we explore the reasons many of us fail to stand up to unjust rules and authority.
你会怎么做？这个问题引人入胜，因为虽然我们都喜欢认为自己会做出勇敢的事、正确的事，但我们许多人心里隐隐有一种怀疑，觉得自己可能不会。我们害怕自己会像其他人一样随波逐流，去做被要求做的事。今天在节目中，我们探讨了我们当中许多人未能对不公正的规则和权威挺身而出的原因。
Not just to dictators or people perpetrating crimes against humanity, but to petty tyrants in the workplace, unfair rules in our cities, even mean-spirited gossip in our circle of friends. Why we silence ourselves and how we can align our words and actions with our values this week on Hidden Brain. All of us can remember moments when we stepped up to do the right thing. Maybe we helped a fellow student who was on the receiving end of hurtful barbs. Maybe we defied orders that we knew were wrong. Looking back, we remember these moments with pride.
不仅是对独裁者或犯下反人类罪行的人，还有对职场中的微型暴君、我们城市中不公平的规则，甚至是朋友圈里刻薄的八卦。本周的《隐藏的大脑》将探讨我们为何选择沉默，以及我们如何让自己的言行与价值观保持一致。我们所有人都能回想起那些我们挺身而出做正确之事的时刻。也许我们帮助了一位成为恶毒言语攻击对象的同学。也许我们违抗了我们明知是错误的命令。回首过去，我们满怀自豪地铭记这些时刻。
But all of us also remember other moments. Moments of silence, of cowardice. We don't post about such moments on our social media feeds, but we do ask ourselves afterwards, why didn't I say something? Why didn't I do something? At Cornell University, psychologist Sunita Sa studies why we stay silent when we know we should speak and how to rediscover our voices. Sunita Sa, welcome to Hidden Brain.
但我们所有人也记得其他时刻。那些保持沉默、表现得懦弱的时刻。我们不会在社交媒体上发布这样的时刻，但在事后，我们会问自己：我为什么不说点什么？我为什么不做点什么？在康奈尔大学，心理学家苏妮塔·萨（Sunita Sah）研究了为什么当我们需要发声时却选择保持沉默，以及如何重新找回我们的声音。苏妮塔·萨，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。
It's wonderful to be here. Thank you. Sunita, I want to take you back to your days in Pittsburgh. There was an evening one day when you felt a sudden pain in your chest. Can you tell me what happened? Yes. I had this immense chest pain. And it was a pain that I had not felt before and so I thought I should do something about this and I ended up going to the emergency room in Pittsburgh, which is one of my first experiences of the healthcare service in the US having moved from the UK and it was very efficient. Within minutes, I was actually through triage
很高兴来到这里。谢谢你。苏妮塔，我想带你回到你在匹兹堡的日子。有一天晚上，你感到胸口一阵突如其来的疼痛。你能告诉我发生了什么吗？是的。我当时胸口剧痛。这种疼痛是我以前从未感受过的，所以我认为我应该对此采取点行动。最后我去了匹兹堡的一家急诊室。自从从英国搬到美国后，这是我第一次体验美国的医疗服务，效率非常高。几分钟内，我实际上就完成了分诊，
and a nurse had pushed me into an examination room and they did a lot of tests, including an electrocardiogram to make sure there was nothing wrong with my heart, which was my primary concern. And everything was fine. So I was relieved and my pain was going down a little bit. And I told the doctor and I thought I was about to get released from the emergency room. And she said, well, actually, just before you go, I would like you to have a CT scan. And so I was like, oh, I wonder why. Why is that? And she said, just to make sure that you don't have a pulmonary embolism. Sunita had worked as a doctor in the UK before moving to the United States.
护士把我推进了检查室，他们做了很多检查，包括心电图，以确保我的心脏没有问题，这是我最关心的。一切都很好。所以我松了一口气，疼痛也在减轻。我把这告诉了医生，以为自己马上就要离开急诊室了。但她说，嗯，其实，在你走之前，我想让你做个CT扫描。所以我当时想，哦，我不知道为什么。为什么要做这个？她说，只是为了确保你没有肺栓塞。苏妮塔在搬到美国之前曾在英国当过医生。
She knew the symptoms of a pulmonary embolism, which is a blockage in the lungs that's caused by a blood clot. A pulmonary embolism causes what we call pleuritic chest pain. And this is a sharp pain. It catches your breath when you inhale and exhale. That was not the type of pain that I was experiencing. I just did not think that I had this embolism in my lungs. And so I did not think the CT scan was necessary, and I didn't want it. Because why expose yourself to ionizing radiation if you don't need it? I mean, with a CT scan, it's about 70 times more on average than the radiation you get from an x-ray.
她知道肺栓塞的症状，肺栓塞是由血栓引起的肺部堵塞。肺栓塞会导致我们所说的胸膜炎性胸痛。这是一种尖锐的疼痛。当你吸气和呼气时，它会让你喘不过气来。那不是我当时经历的那种疼痛。我根本不认为我的肺里有这种栓塞。因此，我认为CT扫描是没有必要的，我也不想做。因为如果你不需要，为什么要让自己暴露在电离辐射下呢？我的意思是，做一次CT扫描，平均受到的辐射大约是你照X光时的70倍。
It's still small, but why have it if you don't need it? And so I should have said no to the CT scan and yet I didn't. Moments later, Sunita found herself getting prepped for the scan. She turned to the tech and asked how much radiation the scan entailed. Sunita didn't need to ask the question. I knew how much radiation was in the CT scan. And so I wanted her to say, oh, are you comfortable with that? I wanted her to ask me so I could say, actually, no, I'm not. Do I really need this? And she didn't. She didn't. She just hesitated and then I carried on. I carried on having the CT scan.
它仍然很小，但如果你不需要，为什么要去做呢？所以我本该对CT扫描说不，然而我没有。片刻之后，苏妮塔发现自己正在为扫描做准备。她转向技术员，询问扫描需要多少辐射。苏妮塔其实不需要问这个问题。我知道CT扫描里有多少辐射。所以我希望技术员说，哦，你对这个感到适应吗？我希望她问我，这样我就可以说，实际上，不，我不是很适应。我真的需要这个吗？但她没有。她没有。她只是犹豫了一下，然后我继续了。我继续进行了CT扫描。
And I was like, oh, this is not working. People are not registering my discomfort. And so I just lay back in the scanner and was perplexed why I couldn't say no. I'm assuming you didn't have a pulmonary embolism. No, the images showed everything was clear, everything was fine, and I regretted so much not being able to speak up and just say, I don't think I have a pulmonary embolism.
当时我想，哦，这行不通。人们没有注意到我的不适。于是我重新躺回扫描仪里，感到困惑为什么我说不出不字。我猜你没有肺栓塞吧？没有，影像显示一切都很清晰，一切都很好，我非常后悔当时没能大声说出来，只是说：我觉得我没有肺栓塞。
I would just want to go home. I so regretted that. I want to ask you about another story, Sunita. You have a friend named Rick who was experiencing some lower back pain, and he decided that he was going to go in to get a massage. What happened? Yes, his doctor had actually recommended for his lower back pain,
我只想回家。我对此后悔莫不及。我想问你另一个故事，苏妮塔。你有一个朋友叫瑞克，他经历了一些下背痛，他决定去做个按摩。发生了什么？是的，他的医生其实建议他针对下背痛，
for him to do some stretching, some exercises, and that a deep tissue massage would probably help. So he booked one in New York City and he was really looking forward to having some relief from his pain. And he walked in, the place was just very serene. It was a nice scented room, candles, lovely music playing. The massage therapist told him to get onto the massage table and he did and thought, this is amazing. Then the massage therapist came in and he put two warm hands onto Rick's back and then all of a, he dug his elbow in really sharp into his trapezius muscle, which is near the top of his back.
做一些伸展运动，并认为深层组织按摩可能会有所帮助。于是在纽约市，他预约了一场按摩，并且非常期待能缓解他的疼痛。他走了进去，那个地方非常宁静。那是一个带有香味的房间、点着蜡烛、播放着悦耳音乐的房间。按摩师让他趴到按摩床上，他照做了，并心想，这太棒了。接着按摩师走了进来，把两只温暖的手放在瑞克的背上。紧接着，他突然把手肘狠狠地扎进瑞克的斜方肌里，那是靠近背部上方的地方。
And immediately, Rick wanted to say something. He wanted to scream out and say, ah, but he didn't. He hesitated and thought, okay, that's just the first, that's just the first part of the massage. But then it continued over and over. And each time the elbow dug into his back, his upper and his lower back and all along, he was just trying to stifle all this pain and screams. He just didn't say a word.
瑞克立刻想说点什么。他想尖叫出来说“啊”，但他没有。他犹豫了一下，心想，好吧，这只是第一步，这只是按摩的第一部分。但接着这种动作一遍又一遍地继续。每次手肘扎进他的背部、他的上背部和下背部时，他一路上都在试图强忍住所有的疼痛和尖叫。他硬是一个字也没说。
He wanted to, but he could not say anything. I understand that Rick not only left without saying anything but he added a tip for the massage therapist on his way out? That's right. He thanked the massage therapist and then paid him and gave him a tip and then had a very painful subway ride back home.
他很想说，但他什么也说不出来。我听说瑞克不仅离开时什么也没说，而且在离开的路上还给按摩师留了小费？是的。他感谢了按摩师，然后付了钱并给了小费，随后经历了一趟非常痛苦的地铁回家之旅。
Once he got home, he told his wife about this massage and she said that's not normal why didn't you say anything and he was like well I didn't want him to think that he wasn't doing his job properly I thought this is how massages go so I just couldn't say anything to him. And she said, so you'd rather have him hurt you than you hurt his feelings. And he was like, exactly. Ha ha ha. Ha ha ha.
回到家后，他把这次按摩的经历告诉了妻子，妻子说这太不正常了，你当时怎么不说出来？他说，嗯，我不想让他觉得自己工作没做好，我以为按摩就是这样的，所以我什么也对他说不出口。妻子说，所以你宁愿让他伤害你，也不愿伤害他的感情。他说，完全正确。哈哈哈哈。哈哈哈哈。
Sunita has asked herself how she and so many other people she knows have become so compliant. In her case, she traced it back to her family upbringing. When I was young, I remember asking my dad, what does my name Sunita mean? And he said, oh, in Sanskrit, Sunita means good. And so mostly I lived up to that. I was known for being an obedient daughter and student. So I did what I was told, I did my homework
苏妮塔曾问过自己，她和她认识的许多其他人是怎么变得如此顺从的。就她而言，她把这追溯到了她的家庭教育。年轻时，我记得我问过爸爸，我的名字苏妮塔是什么意思？他说，哦，在梵文中，苏妮塔的意思是“好”。所以基本上我一直是按这个标准生活的。我以做一个听话的女儿和学生而闻名。所以我做被要求做的事，我做家庭作业
the way that they wanted me to and expected. I even had my hair cut the way my parents insisted. And these were the messages I received, not just from my family, but from the community and from teachers, is to be good, to be polite, to obey, not to question authority. And mostly I lived up to that. I understand your parents were fairly strict with you and at one point your dad would wake
按照他们想要的方式和预期。甚至连我的头发也是按照父母坚持的方式剪的。这些是我收到的信息，不仅来自我的家庭，还来自社区和老师，那就是要做好孩子、要有礼貌、要顺从、不要质疑权威。基本上我一直是按这个标准生活的。我听说你的父母对你相当严格，有一点你爸爸甚至会把你
you up in the middle of the night to practice your skills. I mean, that's pretty intense. Yes. And I think this is maybe a dynamics that is familiar to first generation children of immigrants. So I do remember my dad getting me out of bed in the middle of the night because I hadn't practiced my flutes and I had to do the scales. Some time ago, Sunita noticed she was being similarly demanding of her own son. So we were in London around 2012 for the Olympics, and I was really excited because the Olympic flame was going to pass
从睡梦中叫醒来练习技能。我的意思是，这相当激烈。是的。我想这可能是一代移民子女所熟悉的一种动态。我确实记得我爸爸半夜把我从床上拉起来，因为我没有练习长笛，我必须练习音阶。一段时间前，苏妮塔注意到她对自己的儿子也有着同样苛刻的要求。所以我们在2012年前后去伦敦观看奥运会，我非常兴奋，因为奥运火炬将经过
where I used to live in London, and I wanted to take him with me to see the flame. And he was nearly five years old, and we were walking along. It was a hot day and he was tired because he'd already been out in the morning and he didn't want to go. So he kept holding me back and I told him to hurry up, come. And then he just like, no, I don't want to go. He was jutting his chin out and I know that look very, very well now and he just refused to go. So I tried to pick him up and carry him. He was jutting his chin out and I know that look very, very well now. And he just refused to go. So I tried to pick him up and carry him. He was too heavy and he just sat down in the middle of the pavement. And whatever I said, I couldn't make him
我在伦敦曾经住过的地方，我想带他一起去看火炬。他快五岁了，我们正走在路上。那天很热，他因为早上已经出去了而感到疲惫，他不想去。所以他一直拖我的后腿，我催他快点、走。然后他就像，不，我不想去。他把下巴翘得高高的，我现在对那个表情非常非常熟悉，他就是拒绝去。所以我试图把他抱起来走。他把下巴翘得高高的，我现在对那个表情非常非常熟悉。他就是拒绝去。所以我试图把他抱起来走。他太重了，直接坐在了人行道中间。无论我说什么，我都无法让他
go. So I had to give up on seeing the flame and I walked back home with him. And I looked at him and I said, why can't you just be good? And those words stayed with me afterwards. Because I remember telling my husband about it in the evening and he was like, you sound like those people. Do you remember? And I do. I remember when my son was born, he was a little baby and well-meaning relatives would always be asking me, oh, is he good? And I was confused, like, what do you mean is he good? He's a baby. What they meant was, does he sleep when you want him to? Does he eat when you want him to? Does he do what you want him to do? And this was a powerful realization for me that if we equate being good with being compliant,
前行。所以我不得不放弃看火炬，带着他走回了家。我看着他，对他说：“你就不能乖一点吗？”那些话之后一直留在我心里。因为我记得那天晚上我把这件事告诉丈夫时，他说：“你听起来就像那些人。你还记得吗？”我记得。我记得我儿子出生时，他还只是个小婴儿，好心的亲戚总是问我：“哦，他乖吗？”我很困惑，心想：你说的乖是什么意思？他只是个婴儿。他们的意思是：你想让他睡时他会睡吗？你想让他吃时他会吃吗？他会做你想让他做的事吗？这对我来说是一个重大的顿悟：如果我们把“乖”等同于顺从、
doing what other people want, then we equate also being defiant with being bad. And that's what I was brought up like. So that kept me awake that night for sure. Think about the last time you were on a plane or train or bus. Sitting nearby were two families. Both had small infants with them. One was calm and compliant, the other shrieked and screamed. Did you find yourself marveling at the good kid and annoyed by the bad kid? If you're a teacher, do you find yourself drawn to angelic children who follow the rules
做别人想要的事，那么我们也就会把“叛逆”等同于“坏”。而我就是这样被抚养长大的。那晚这绝对让我彻夜难眠。想想你上次坐飞机、火车或公交车的情景。坐在附近的是两个家庭。两家都带着小婴儿。一个安静且顺从，另一个大喊大叫。你有没有发现自己惊叹于那个好孩子，并对那个坏孩子感到恼火？如果你是一名老师，你是否发现自己会被那些遵守规则的天使般的孩子所吸引，
and find yourself exasperated by kids who constantly test the limits? When we come back, the psychological drivers that prompt us to fall in line and how they can lead us astray. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. All of us need to follow rules. When you live in a country where people drive on the right, you cannot suddenly decide to drive on the left.
而对那些不断试探底线的小孩感到恼怒？稍后回来，我们将探讨驱使我们随波逐流的心理驱动力，以及它们如何将我们引入歧途。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们所有人都需要遵守规则。当你生活在一个靠右行驶的国家时，你不能突然决定靠左行驶。
Well, you can, but you'll quickly get in a crash. We expect schools and stores to be open when they say they will be open, and we expect courts and cops to come to our aid when someone breaks the law and harms us. But while rules do many good things in our lives, they can also turn us into unthinking automatons. At Cornell University, Sunita Sa studies the psychology of compliance and defiance. Sunita, in April 2004, an assistant manager at a Kentucky McDonald's gets a call
嗯，你可以，但你很快就会发生车祸。我们期望学校和商店在它们声称营业的时候开门，我们期望当有人违法并伤害我们时，法庭和警察能来帮助我们。但是，虽然规则在我们的生活中发挥了许多好作用，它们也能把我们变成不加思考的自动化机器人。在康奈尔大学，苏妮塔·萨研究顺从与叛逆的心理学。苏妮塔，2004年4月，肯塔基州一家麦当劳的一位副经理接到了一通电话，
from a police officer. Set the scene for me, Sunita. Who was this manager and what was the call about? So the manager, her name was Donna Summers. She's an assistant manager in her early 50s, and she's worked here for a while. At 5pm, the phone rings in the small back office, and online is just a deep male voice, someone who identifies himself as Officer Scott. And he says he's investigating a theft. So a customer has had her purse stolen and he describes the person that they think has stolen the purse. That person is a young girl about 90 pounds with
来自一名警官。苏妮塔，请为我还原一下当时的场景。这位经理是谁？这通电话是关于什么的？所以这位经理，她的名字叫唐娜·萨莫斯（Donna Summers）。她是一位50岁出头的副经理，在这里工作了一段时间。下午5点，后方小办公室里的电话铃响了，电话那头是一个低沉的男声，自称是斯科特警官。他说他在调查一起盗窃案。所以有一位顾客的钱包被偷了，他描述了他们认为偷钱包的人的特征。那是一个90磅左右的年轻女孩，
dark brown hair. So immediately Donna Summers says, that's Louise. But she's surprised because Louise is quite irresponsible. She's a high school senior and she's never been known for being dishonest in any way. She's hardworking, she's bound for college, she's looking after her sick mother, and yet that is who they identify as responsible for this theft. The officer cites various laws and criminal statutes that Louise allegedly broke. He tells Donna he has her supervisor, a woman named Lisa Siddons, on the other line. So Officer Scott tells her that they are also investigating Louise for dealing drugs. And it's very serious.
留着深棕色头发。所以唐娜·萨莫斯立刻说，那是路易丝。但她很惊讶，因为路易丝相当靠谱。她是名高中高年级学生，而且从来没有做出过任何不诚实的行为。她很勤奋，准备上大学，还要照顾生病的母亲，然而这正是他们认定的盗窃案嫌疑人。这位警官引用了路易丝涉嫌违反的各种法律和刑事法规。他告诉唐娜，他的另一条线上有她的主管，一个叫莉萨·西登斯（Lisa Siddons）的女人。所以斯科特警官告诉她，他们也在调查路易丝贩毒的事情。而且这非常严重。
The officers are on their way and they need to detain the suspect as soon as possible. They don't want the suspect to get away, and they don't want her to get rid of any evidence. So they request Donna Summers restrain the suspect Louise in the back office and follow their instructions. Donna Summers brings Louise to the back office. Officer Scott is still on the phone.
警察正在赶来的路上，他们需要尽快拘留嫌疑人。他们不想让嫌疑人逃跑，也不想让她销毁任何证据。因此，他们要求唐娜·萨莫斯将嫌疑人路易丝扣留在后方的办公室里，并听从他们的指示。唐娜·萨莫斯把路易丝带到了后方办公室。斯科特警官还在电话里。
A note that this next part of the story involves physical and sexual assault. So Officer Scott is on the cordless telephone giving orders, and he orders Donner Summers to conduct a strip search first of all. So Summers does. She asks Louise to remove every item of clothing. She shakes each item and places it in a plastic bag. And even though Louise starts crying and Summers comforts her and she thinks that the strip search is over the top, she thinks that she must obey authority. She must obey the police officer. She must obey authority. She must obey the police officer. It's cold in the back room. By this point, Louise is wearing only a McDonald's apron. When Donna Summers tells the police officer she needs to attend to the evening rush at the restaurant,
请注意，故事的接下来部分涉及身体和性侵犯。所以斯科特警官在无绳电话上发号施令，他命令唐娜·萨莫斯首先对路易丝进行脱衣搜身。于是萨莫斯照做了。她要求路易丝脱掉所有衣物。她抖动每一件衣物，并将其放入塑料袋中。尽管路易丝开始哭泣，萨莫斯安慰了她，并且她认为脱衣搜身有些过分了，但她认为自己必须服从权威。她必须服从警官。她必须服从权威。她必须服从警官。后屋很冷。此时，路易丝身上只穿着一件麦当劳围裙。当唐娜·萨莫斯告诉警官她需要去处理餐厅晚间的高峰客流时，
he asks her to bring in someone else to watch the teenager. So she asks Jason Bradley, who is a 27-year-old cook, to take over. So Jason comes, he takes over the phone, and Officer Scott demands that Louise drops her apron so she can see whether she's hiding any evidence. Jason refuses to be a part of the strip search. He hands the phone back to Donna Summers and returns to the kitchen. So at this point Donna Summers says that she can't spare any more staff because it's getting really busy in the McDonald's and Officer Scott asks whether she is married and she said
他让她找另一个人来看着这个青少年。于是她找了27岁的厨师杰森·布拉德利（Jason Bradley）来接替。于是杰森来了，他接听了电话，斯科特警官要求路易丝脱掉围裙，以便他能看看她是否藏有任何证据。杰森拒绝参与脱衣搜身。他把电话还给唐娜·萨莫斯，回到了厨房。此时唐娜·萨莫斯说她抽不出更多人手了，因为麦当劳里变得非常忙碌，斯科特警官问她是否结婚了，然后她说
she's engaged and he asks her, do you trust him? And she says, yes. And he tells her to call, call him, call your fiance. Donna Summers asks her fiance to come to her workplace. Walter Nix coaches youth baseball. He's a regular church goer. But once in the back room, alone with the frightened teenager,
她订婚了，他问她：你相信他吗？她说：是的。然后他让她打电话，给他打电话，给你的未婚夫打电话。唐娜·萨默斯让她的未婚夫来到她的工作场所。沃尔特·尼克斯是青年棒球队的教练。他是个经常去教堂的人。但是一旦到了后面的房间里，和一个惊恐的 teenager（青少年）单独在一起时，
he obediently follows the instructions of the voice on the phone. So over the next two hours, Officer Scott asks him to do an array of different physical and sexual abuse to Louise. And he agrees, and he conducts this abuse. this abuse. So at the end of this period Walter Nix finally leaves and Donna Summers comes back. He goes to his car, Walter Nix goes to his car, but he recognizes that he has done something that he shouldn't have done. What happens
他顺从地听从了电话那头声音的指令。所以在接下来的两个小时里，斯科特警官要求他对路易丝实施一系列不同的身体和性虐待。他同意了，并且实施了这种虐待。这种虐待。所以在这一时期结束时，沃尔特·尼克斯终于离开了，唐娜·萨默斯回来了。他走向他的车，沃尔特·尼克斯走向他的车，但他意识到自己做了一件不该做的事。发生了什么
there, Sunita? He rings his friend and he immediately says, I've done something terrible. So it's only when he leaves that he recognizes that this was wrong. And after he's left, Officer Scott continues, he asks Donna Summers who else is there? Is there another man that can monitor Louise. So at that point Donna Summers goes back into the restaurant to look for someone and the only person that she thinks of is Thomas Sims, who's actually a 58 year old maintenance man who is there just on his day off, he's having dessert and coffee. So she asks him to come with her to the back room. And then she hands the phone to him and Officer Scott asks the same thing again. He asked Thomas Sims to tell Louise
苏妮塔？他给他的朋友打电话，立刻说道：我做了一件可怕的事。所以只有当他离开时，他才意识到这是不对的。在他离开后，斯科特警官继续追问，他问唐娜·萨默斯还有谁在那里？还有没有其他男人可以看守路易丝。所以在那个时候，唐娜·萨默斯回到餐馆里寻找某个人，她唯一能想到的人是托马斯·西姆斯，他其实是一名58岁的维修工，那天正好休假，正在那里吃甜点喝咖啡。于是她请他跟她一起去后面的房间。然后她把电话递给他，斯科特警官又问了同样的问题。他要求托马斯·西姆斯告诉路易丝
to drop her apron so that Thomas can see whether she's concealing any evidence. And Thomas now immediately feels alarmed. And he says, looks directly at Louise, and he says, you keep that apron wrapped around you. And he hands the phone straight away back to Donna Summers, and he says, something's not right about this. This is wrong. So at this point now, the whole ordeal has been almost three hours long. Donna
放下围裙，以便托马斯能看看她是否藏有什么证据。这时托马斯立刻感到警惕。他说，直视着路易丝的眼睛，说道：你把围裙裹在身上。然后他立刻把电话还给唐娜·萨默斯，并说道：这事有点不对劲。这不对。所以在这一点上，整个折磨过程已经持续了将近三个小时。唐娜
Summers was told by Officer Scott that the police were going to be on their way and presumably the police should have gotten there within three hours. Yes that's right but it took Thomas Sims to come in and puncture this compliant atmosphere and say this is wrong for Donna Simmers to really take a step back and think about this. And when Thomas Simmers said these words, she decided like, what's going on? And she picked up her cell phone to call her manager, Lisa Siddons, who officer Scott said was on the other line. And Lisa says, what are you talking about? And only then does she realize that this is a hoax.
萨默斯被斯科特警官告知警察已经在路上了，按理说警察应该在三小时内到达。是的，没错，但正是因为托马斯·西姆斯的介入，打破了这种顺从的氛围，并说这不对，才让唐娜·萨默斯真正退后一步并思考这件事。当托马斯·西姆斯说出这些话时，她决定想一想：这到底是怎么回事？于是她拿起手机给经理丽莎·西登斯打电话，斯科特警官曾说她在另一条线上。丽莎说：你在说什么？直到这时她才意识到这是一个骗局。
She puts the other phone to her ear and the line is dead. Talk a moment about the fact that as Donna Summers picks up this call, the officer is citing various police codes and statutes. She decides to take that first step of calling Louise to the back room and from that point on each action is only one small step beyond the previous action. Talk about this process of gradual escalation Sunita. You're like the frog in the proverbial hot water,
她把另一部电话凑到耳边，电话已经断线了。请谈谈这样一个事实：当唐娜·萨默斯接起这通电话时，警官正在引用各种警察法典和法规。她决定迈出第一步，叫路易丝去后面的房间，从那时起，每一个行动都只是比前一个行动多出的一小步。请谈谈这种逐渐升级的过程，苏妮塔。你就像谚语里温水煮青蛙中的那只青蛙，
you're not aware that you're being boiled. That's right, once you start complying you do a little bit more and a little bit more and then at what point do you start saying no? It's harder to say no to end the compliance now if you didn't do so early on. What is the line that you draw that this has gone too far now. I want to discuss another aspect of compliance. Shortly after you finished medical school in the United Kingdom, you were invited to a free financial consultation.
你并没有意识到自己正在被煮。没错，一旦你开始顺从，你就会做得多一点，再多一点，然后你在哪个节点开始说不呢？如果你一开始没有这样做，现在要想说不来结束这种顺从就更难了。你划定的界限是什么，即事情现在已经过头了。我想讨论顺从的另一个方面。你在英国读完医学院不久后，就受邀参加了一次免费的财务咨询。
What was your life like at the time? What were the state of your finances and who was offering this financial consultation? I was working as a junior doctor in the UK and I received an invite to meet with a financial advisor for free at work. So I agreed to meet with this financial advisor and I remember that meeting very well. So it was in the hospital's posh meeting room, a room that I didn't even know existed. And I walked in and there was this blue plush carpet.
你当时的生活是怎样的？你的财务状况如何，是谁在提供这份财务咨询？我当时在英国做初级医生，我收到了一份邀请，可以在工作场所与财务顾问进行免费会面。所以我同意与这位财务顾问见面，我把那次会面记得非常清楚。那是在医院豪华的会议室里，一个我甚至不知道它存在的房间。我走进去，里面铺着蓝色的毛绒地毯。
In contrast to the stone cold tiles of the floor, this was a nice change. Sunita sank into the couch. The financial advisor, whose name was Dan, came in. He was very tall, big smile, handsome, very sharp suit and he shook my hand and he spoke to me for a very long time, about an hour, about my, mostly about my finances, which was surprising because I had a very limited disposable income at the time, working as a junior doctor. He built up this fantastic rapport with me. And at the end of an hour, he said that I should invest in a couple of funds and that he would write a report for me about my finances and all this would be for free.
与冰冷的石头瓷砖地面相比，这是一个不错的改变。苏妮塔陷入了沙发里。名叫丹的财务顾问走了进来。他身材高大，笑容灿烂，长相英俊，穿着剪裁利落的西装，他和我握手，并跟我聊了很长时间，大约一个小时，关于我的，主要是关于我的财务状况，这很令人惊讶，因为我当时作为初级医生，可支配收入非常有限。他和我建立了这种美妙的融洽关系。一个小时结束时，他说我应该投资几只基金，他会为我写一份关于我财务状况的报告，所有这一切都是免费的。
So I was impressed. It sounds great. And since I was tired, I did blurt out, what's in it for you? Well he responded with, there's no such thing as a free lunch. And I remember being surprised then because I was working as a junior doctor and we got free lunches all the time from the pharmaceutical drugs. And so my eyes got wider and he carried on and he said, no, there's no such thing as a free lunch.
所以我印象深刻。听起来很棒。既然我很累，我不禁脱口而出：你有什么企图？嗯，他回答说：没有免费的午餐。我记得当时我很惊讶，因为我是一名初级医生，我们经常从制药公司那里得到免费午餐。所以我的眼睛睁得更大，他继续说道：不，没有免费的午餐。
I'm going to receive a commission if you invest in the funds that I'm recommending today. So in other words, he's told you that he has something of a conflict of interest in the advice that he's giving you. What was your reaction at this point? So yeah, I mean that disclosure of the conflict of interest changed the dynamics of the situation for me. So I did feel less trust in the advice that he was giving me to invest in these funds. But at the same time, I didn't want Dan to know that I no longer trusted him. I didn't want him to know that his disclosure had corrupted the good rapport that we'd built up and this relationship that we now had over the last hour. And so I started to feel more uncomfortable. I actually felt more pressure to sign and say
如果你投资我今天推荐的基金，我将获得佣金。换句话说，他告诉你他对你提出的建议存在某种利益冲突。你当时的反应是什么？所以，是的，我的意思是利益冲突的披露改变了这种情况对我的动态。因此，对于他给我的投资这些基金的建议，我确实感到信任度降低了。但与此同时，我不想让丹知道我不再信任他。我不想让他知道他的披露破坏了我们过去一小时建立的良好融洽关系以及我们现在拥有的这种关系。因此我开始感到更加不舒服。我实际上感到更大的压力去签字并说
that I will take the funds advice, I will invest in the funds that he is recommending. Because if I don't take his advice now, I'm essentially depriving him of his commission. So both I felt that pressure to be helpful, but I also felt a lot of pressure not to signal distress. So you've come up with a term that I love called insinuation anxiety. What is insinuation anxiety, Sunita? So insinuation anxiety is a distinct type of anxiety that arises when people worry that their non-compliance with another person's wishes may be interpreted as a signal of distrust. Insinuating that the person is not whom they appear to be or should be. So we don't want to insinuate that, for example, our advisors, our co-workers, or even our
我会接受基金的建议，我会投资他推荐的基金。因为如果我现在不接受他的建议，我本质上就是在剥夺他的佣金。因此，一方面我感到了要做到乐于助人的压力，另一方面我也感到了不要表现出不安的巨大压力。所以你想出了一个我非常喜欢的术语，叫做暗示焦虑。什么是暗示焦虑，苏妮塔？所以暗示焦虑是一种独特的焦虑类型，当人们担心他们对他人意愿的不顺从可能被解释为不信任的信号时就会产生这种焦虑。暗示这个人并不是他们看起来的那样，或者不应该是那样。所以我们不想暗示，例如，我们的顾问、同事，甚至是我们的
friends and our family are not trustworthy, that they're incompetent, or they're biased, or even corrupt. And this anxiety increases the pressure to comply with another person. You conducted a very interesting experiment on a ferry in Long Island. Tell me about that experiment and what you found. We had a middle-aged white man go up to passengers, just over 250 passengers, to ask them to fill out a very short survey. So it was an innocuous survey
朋友和家人是不值得信任的，他们是不称职的，或者是心怀偏见的，甚至是腐败的。这种焦虑增加了顺从他人的压力。你在长岛的一艘渡轮上做了一个非常有趣的实验。能跟我讲讲那个实验以及你发现了什么吗？我们让一个中年白人男子走向乘客，对两百五十多名乘客进行采访，请他们填写一份非常简短的问卷。所以这是一份无害的问卷，
just asking them, was the ferry running on time? How clean is the ferry? How many people are you traveling with? And for filling out this survey, they would get $5 in cash. So people agreed to fill out this survey. And once they had finished the survey, the man asked them, well, you know, I can give you the $5 as promised, or I can enter you into this lottery, which pays out somewhere between $0 and $10, but the average payment is usually less than $5. What did people do?
只是问他们：渡轮准点了吗？渡轮有多干净？你和多少人一起出行？为了填写这份问卷，他们将获得5美元现金。于是人们同意填写这份问卷。当他们填完问卷后，那名男子问他们：嗯，你知道，我可以按承诺给你5美元，或者我可以把你加入这个抽奖活动，奖金在0到10美元之间，但平均奖金通常少于5美元。人们是怎么做的？
Pretty much everyone went for the cash. Only 8% chose the lottery. And that makes sense because you're getting a sure $5 versus getting something that's likely to be less than $5. Exactly, yeah. So it really shows that the preference for nearly everyone was the $5 cash, the certain $5 bill.
几乎每个人都选择现金。只有8%的人选择了抽奖。这很合理，因为你得到的是确定的5美元，而不是可能少于5美元的东西。没错，是的。所以这确实表明几乎所有人的首选都是5美元现金，那张确定的50美元（此处应为5美元，但根据原文翻译）美元钞票。
But when the man gave advice, I think you should go for the lottery, that went up to 20%. But even more surprising, there was one condition where the man had to reveal his ulterior motive for recommending the lottery, that he would receive a bonus, a commission, if you took the lottery. And so in that way, he was disclosing his conflict of interest, much like Dan, my financial advisor, had disclosed to me. Right. What happened then?
但当那名男子给出建议——“我认为你应该去参加抽奖”时，这一比例上升到了20%。但更令人惊讶的是，有一种情况是，那名男子不得不透露他推荐抽奖的不可告人的动机，即如果你参加抽奖，他将获得奖金、佣金。通过这种方式，他披露了他的利益冲突，很像丹——我的财务顾问向我披露的那样。没错。那接下来发生了什么？
In that condition, compliance with the lottery advice went up to 42%. It more than doubled the advice alone. I mean, it's really puzzling, Sunita, because of course, as you've shown, when you haven't given anyone advice, their preference is just to take the $5. When you give people advice to take the lottery,
在这种情况下，对抽奖建议的顺从度上升到了42%。这比单凭建议的比例翻了一番还多。我的意思是，这真的很令人费解，苏妮塔，因为当然，正如你所展示的那样，当你没有给任何人建议时，他们的首选只是拿走5美元。当你给人们建议去参加抽奖时，
it goes up to 20%. But when you tell people, take the lottery, and I am going to profit if you take the lottery, you would imagine that number should go down, because now people should be suspicious of me and my motives, but the number goes up, it doubles. That's right. And people are suspicious. They trust the advice less. And some even said that they like the man less because of that. But they still went along with it. And the reason is insinuation anxiety. They didn't want the man to know
这个比例会上升到20%。但当你告诉人们：去参加抽奖吧，如果你们参加抽奖我将从中获利，你会想象这个数字应该下降，因为现在人们应该对我和我的动机产生怀疑，但这个数字却上升了，翻了一番。没错。而且人们确实感到了怀疑。他们对这些建议的信任度降低了。有些人甚至说因为这个他们更不喜欢那个男人了。但他们还是顺从而去了。原因就是暗示焦虑。他们不想让那个人知道
that they trusted his advice less. Tell me about the gender patterns you noticed in running this experiment, Sunita. So in this particular experiment with insinuation anxiety and the man giving advice, this insinuation anxiety on compliance occurred only in the women participants. We didn't see it in the men, and we were surprised because other experiments that we had run in different contexts showed no gender difference.
他们对他的建议信任度降低了。能跟我讲讲你在进行这个实验时注意到的性别模式吗，苏妮塔？所以在关于暗示焦虑和男子给出建议的这个特定实验中，这种对顺从的暗示焦虑仅出现在女性参与者身上。我们在男性身上没有看到这一点，我们感到很惊讶，因为我们在不同背景下进行的的其他实验并未显示出性别差异。
But in this one, there was a clear gender difference. Women felt insinuation anxiety much more than men did. And that increased their compliance. So Sunita, you have looked at different fields, aviation and medicine, to see how often people speak up when they see a mistake. So one survey found that nine out of 10 healthcare workers, most of them nurses, don't feel comfortable speaking up when they see a colleague making an error or taking a shortcut. And crew members in commercial airlines, nearly 50% of them, don't want to speak up when they see their superior making a mistake.
但在这次实验中，存在明显的性别差异。女性感受到的暗示焦虑远远多于男性。这增加了她们的顺从度。所以苏妮塔，你曾考察过不同的领域，比如航空和医疗，来看看当人们看到错误时，他们发声的频率如何。一项调查发现，十分之九的医护人员（其中大多数是护士）在看到同事犯错或走捷径时，觉得不愿开口。而商业航空公司的机组人员中，近50%的人在看到上司犯错时不愿意发声。
These can be life and death decisions, and insinuation anxiety can account for some of the reasons why they don't feel comfortable speaking up. I want to talk about another aspect of compliance. Sometimes, you know, we're just swept along by the current, by what everyone around us is doing. You tell the story of a young Marine named Matthew who was deployed to Iraq when he was 19 years old. He's serving near Fallujah, and things are not good when he gets there. So things were not great at all. He was in the middle of a war zone.
这些可能是生死攸关的决定，而暗示焦虑可以解释他们觉得不愿发声的部分原因。我想讨论顺从的另一个方面。有时，你知道，我们只是被潮流、被周围所有人正在做的事情所裹挟。你讲述了一个年轻的海军陆战队员马修的故事，他在19岁时被部署到伊拉克。他在费卢杰附近服役，当他到达那里时，情况并不好。所以情况一点也不好。他身处战区中心。
His friends were getting blown up by various different explosive devices. In fact, his best friend was killed. So at one point, he's in a unit that's basically investigating a neighborhood and they hear an explosive device go off. It's near a mosque. Describe to me the events that happen next, Sunita. it's near a mosque. Describe to me the events that happen next, Sunita. Sunita Chakravartty Yeah, so when this grenade went off, sort of too close for comfort, immediately they hear orders to dismount and to engage. So some of his squad, they run towards the mosque, Matthew, along with others, stay back to provide cover. And when his men came back, they had four young men as prisoners that were dusty, bloody, blindfolded and in handcuffs. So Matthew was given one of the
他的朋友们被各种不同的爆炸装置炸得粉身碎骨。事实上，他最好的朋友牺牲了。所以有一次，他所在的小队正在搜查一个街区，他们听到了一声爆炸装置的响声。它在一个清真寺附近。请向我描述接下来发生的事情，苏妮塔。它在一个清真寺附近。请向我描述接下来发生的事情，苏妮塔。苏妮塔·查克拉瓦蒂：是的，所以当这个手榴弹爆炸时，距离近得让人感到不安，他们立即听到下车并交战的命令。因此他小队的一些人向清真寺跑去，马修和其他人则留在后面提供掩护。当他的人回来时，他们带回了四个年轻的俘虏，他们浑身尘土、血迹斑斑、被蒙住双眼并戴着手铐。所以马修被分配了其中一个
prisoners to basically look after. And his prisoner was yelling at the top of his voice in Arabic, and he couldn't understand him him and neither could his superior. So his superior tells him to shut him up and Matthew asks, what do you mean? What do you want me to do? And his superior says, it's not complicated, hit him in the mouth. And so Matthew looks at the prisoner and he sees blood streaming from his nose into his beard. And he doesn't want to hit this man. He really doesn't, but it's a direct order. His best friend is dead. He doesn't want to be seen as a coward. So he raises his hand and he hits him in the mouth.
基本上需要照看的俘虏。他的俘虏用阿拉伯语大声喊叫，他听不懂，他的上级也听不懂。于是他的上级让他闭嘴，马修问：你是什么意思？你想让我做什么？他的上级说：这并不复杂，打他的嘴。于是马修看着俘虏，看到鲜血从他的鼻子流进胡子里。他不想打这个人。他真的不想，但这是直接命令。他最好的朋友死了。他不想被看作是懦夫。所以他举起手，打了他的嘴。
And then his superior says, he's still talking. Hit him again. Hit him in the stomach. And I remember Matthew looking at me while he's telling the story and he said, so I raised my hand and that's what I did. You know, some time ago Sunita, we spoke with political scientist Timur Koran. He works at Duke University. And many years ago, he came up with this term called preference falsification, where he describes what happens in many societies, where you have a current of some kind is running through a society. Maybe it's someone has come to power and this person is very powerful, or a regime has changed, or some of the work that he did was looking at
然后他的上级说：他还在说话。再打他。打他的肚子。我记得马修在讲这个故事时看着我，他说：于是我举起手，这就是我做的。你知道，一段时间前，苏妮塔，我们采访了政治学家蒂穆尔·库兰。他在杜克大学工作。许多年前，他提出了一个名为“偏好伪造”的术语，他用这个词来描述许多社会中发生的事情，即某种潮流正在社会中蔓延。也许是某人掌权了，而这个人非常强大，或者政权发生了更迭，或者他做的一些工作是关于
East Germany after the fall of the communists and integration with West Germany. And he finds that in many of these societies, what happens is that as people sense that the tides have turned, that the current has changed, they have a very strong impulse to basically fall in line with whatever the prevailing current is. And the idea of preference falsification is I have preferences, but I'm going to in some ways suppress my preferences. I'm going to falsify my preferences because my
共产主义垮台后以及与西德统一后的东德。他发现，在许多这样的社会中，发生的事情是，当人们感觉到风向已经转变、潮流已经改变时，他们有一种非常强烈的冲动，基本上要顺应无论什么盛行的潮流。而偏好伪造的概念是，我有偏好，但我将在某些方面压抑我的偏好。我要伪造我的偏好，因为我的
preferences are out of line with what the majority seems to want. You know, in the classic example, you know, he describes the story of a reporter going to East Germany shortly after reunification with West Germany, and the reporter is trying to find former communists to speak with to ask how they are faring under reunification. And when he gets there, all the communists tell him, you know, I never really was a communist in the first place. I was just pretending to go along with the old regime, and you know I always was for capitalism, I always was for the West. One of the points that Timur Koran makes is that it's really really difficult
偏好与大多数人似乎想要的东西不一致。你知道，在经典例子中，你知道，他描述了一个记者在与西德重新统一后不久前往东德的故事，这位记者试图寻找前共产党员交谈，询问他们在重新统一后的境况如何。当他到达那里时，所有的共产党员都告诉他：你知道，我一开始根本就不是共产党员。我只是假装顺从旧政权，你知道我一直支持资本主义，我一直支持西方。蒂穆尔·库兰提出的观点之一是，真的非常非常困难
for individuals to break out of this when this happens to them. It's one thing to notice it or even to smile about it when it happens to someone else in another country, very difficult to do something when you yourself feel swept up by the tides around you. That's really fascinating to hear, and it aligns with some of my research as well. If you don't admit to yourself or to someone else that you feel something is wrong in this particular situation, if you don't say that you're uncomfortable with it, it's easy to convince yourself that you felt a different way at some point. I mean cognitive dissonance is very strong as we can see.
对于个人来说，当这种情况发生在他们身上时，很难从中脱身。注意到这一点，甚至在它发生在另一个国家的其他人身上时对此微微一笑是一回事，而当你自己感到被周围的潮流所裹挟时，要做点什么就非常困难了。听到这些真的很着迷，这也符合我的一些研究。如果你不向自己或其他人承认你觉得在这种特定情况下有什么不对劲，如果你不说你对此感到不舒服，你很容易说服自己在某个时刻你其实有不同的感受。我的意思是，正如我们所看到的，认知失调是非常强大的。
A great deal of our role following is not conscious and deliberate. It's implicit and automatic. Most of the time we are so compliant we don't even realize we are being compliant. When we come back, how to regain a sense of agency? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Every country in the world has its national monuments to recognize and remember its heroes. These heroes are invariably people who stepped up to do dangerous, difficult, and courageous things in moments of crisis.
我们的很多角色扮演并非是有意识和深思熟虑的。它是内隐且自动的。大多数时候我们如此顺从，以至于我们甚至没有意识到自己正在顺从。当我们回来时，如何重新获得能动性？你正在收听的是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。世界上每个国家都有其国家纪念碑，用于识别和铭记其英雄。这些英雄无一例外都是在危机时刻挺身而出，去做危险、困难和勇敢事情的人。
They are the stars of our history books, our beacons of inspiration. Psychologist Sunita Sa is the author of Defy, the power of no in a world that demands yes. She says one common lesson from the heroes in our history books is that they listen to their inner voices in times of crisis. Think back to that horrific case of impersonation at the McDonald's. Some employees rebelled against Officer Scott's instructions and others complied, but every one of them felt a defining inner emotion. They felt tension, something that I call resistance against resistance, the resistance to resist,
它们是我们历史书中的明星，是我们灵感的灯塔。心理学家苏尼塔·萨（Sunita Sa）是《违抗：在一个要求服从的世界中说“不”的力量》一书的作者。她说，我们历史书中的英雄们带来的一个共同教训是，他们在危机时刻倾听自己内心的声音。回想一下麦当劳那起骇人听闻的冒充事件。一些员工反抗了斯科特警官的指令，而另他们则选择服从，但每个人都感受到了一种决定性的内在情绪。他们感到紧张，我称之为对抗抗拒的抗拒，即抗拒的抗拒，
which is that they felt this tension between what they thought was the right thing to do and the tension to go along with what others expected of them. So obviously, most of us don't like being tense. We don't like being stressed. But you say that this tension actually can play a very salutary role in our lives. How so? Well, if we think about that tension, it can actually be a warning sign to us that something is wrong and that we should pay attention to that. It could be the first signal that you should defy before you even consciously know that you want to defy. And I recognize that tension in them because that's the kind of tension I have
也就是他们在他们认为正确的事情与顺从他人期望的压力之间感到了这种紧张。所以显而易见，我们大多数人都不喜欢紧张。我们不喜欢感到有压力。但你说这种紧张实际上在我们的生活中可以起到非常积极的作用？为什么这么说？嗯，如果我们思考这种紧张，它实际上可以成为我们的一个警告信号，表明出了问题，我们应该予以关注。它可能是你想要违抗的第一个信号，甚至在你清醒地意识到自己想要违抗之前。我能从他们身上认出那种紧张，因为那就是我所感受到的那类紧张
felt when I want to defy but feel strong pressure to comply with what somebody else is telling me. And it can show up in different ways for different people, but we often experience that kind of tension when we want to go against something. So, instead of ignoring it or sweeping it away or thinking it's not worth our doubt, we should really think about what that tension means and whether this really means this is the time to act, this is the time to speak up. I want to go back to the story you told me about how when you had just finished medical
当我想要违抗，但又感到必须服从别人对我的要求的巨大压力时。对于不同的人，它可能会以不同的方式表现出来，但当我们想要反对某事时，我们经常会体验到那种紧张。因此，我们不应该忽视它、将其扫开或认为它不值得我们怀疑，而应该真正思考这种紧张意味着什么，以及这是否真的是行动的时候，这是否真的是大声说出来的时候。我想回到你之前告诉我的一件事，当时你刚结束医学
school in the UK and you were weighing how to manage your relatively meager savings, you met this charming financial advisor named Dan who told you that he stood to benefit if you chose his recommended investments. Did you go ahead and take Dan's advice, Sunita? Well, I felt immense pressure to just sign in front of him, but as soon as things started getting really awkward, my pager actually started beeping. So I had to tell him there's an emergency, a medical emergency, I have to go. And he was fine. He looked a bit deflated to begin with, but then he was, that's okay. I will send you everything and you can sign the paperwork later on. And
在英国的学习，你在权衡如何管理你那微薄的储蓄时，你遇到了这位迷人的财务顾问丹，他告诉你，如果你选择了他推荐的投资，他将从中受益。苏尼塔，你当时真的听取了丹的建议吗？嗯，我感到了巨大的压力，只想在他面前签字，但就在事情开始变得真正尴尬的时候，我的寻呼机突然响了起来。所以我不得不告诉他有紧急情况，医疗紧急情况，我必须走了。他对此表示理解。他起初看起来有点泄气，但接着他说，没关系。我会把一切都发给你，你以后再签署文件。而
that allowed me to exit the situation, which I now call the power of the pause because it allowed me to not have to send a signal of distress back to him. When I got the papers a week later and I didn't have to sign on the dotted line in front of them, I could much more easily assess my very low income and so I threw the papers away. In some ways this points to one of the most important pieces of advice you have when people are dealing with whether to consent to something or to defy something and that is to buy themselves time. Exactly. Ask for some time to think about it. Step away from the situation. Physically if you can would be great and psychologically if you can't.
这让我得以脱身，我现在称之为“暂停的力量”，因为它让我不必向他发出痛苦的信号。一周后我拿到文件时，不必当面在虚线上签字，我可以更轻松地评估我那非常低的收入，所以我把文件撕了。在某种程度上，这指出了你给人们的重要建议之一，当人们在处理是否同意某事还是违抗某事时，那就是为自己争取时间。没错。要求给点时间考虑。离开这个环境。如果可以的话，最好是在物理上离开，如果做不到，就在心理上离开。
So I feel like this happens all the time in so many different situations. You know you're buying a car and the salesperson basically tries to pressure you into making a decision quickly, or you're sitting in a dentist's chair and the dentist says, you know, we need to do this and that, or here's the procedure we need to do. There's a great amount of pressure for us to act quickly. And of course, when we have to act quickly, it becomes much more likely that we will act in compliant ways. That's right. Especially if something is seen as an emergency, it becomes very difficult to say no. A lot of times we can take more time to think about a decision.
所以我觉得这种事在很多不同的情况下一直在发生。你知道，你正在买车，销售人员基本上试图向你施压，让你迅速做出决定，或者你坐在牙医椅上，牙医说，你知道，我们需要做这个和那个，或者这是我们需要做的手术。我们面临着迅速行动的巨大压力。当然，当我们必须迅速行动时，我们顺从行事的可能性就会大大增加。没错。特别是如果某事被视为紧急情况，说“不”就会变得非常困难。很多时候，我们可以花更多时间来思考一个决定。
We don't need to make decisions in the heat of the moment. So we can step away. We can take the power of the pause. And one thing that I've learned about defiance that is really helpful is that if you can take the power of the pause, it is great. But surprise often disables defiance. And anticipation enables defiance. So preparing for situations like that in advance is particularly helpful
我们不需要在情绪激动时做出决定。所以我们可以走开。我们可以运用暂停的力量。关于违抗，我学到的一件非常有用的事情是，如果你能利用暂停的力量，那就太好了。但突发情况往往会削弱违抗能力。而提前预期则能促成违抗。因此，提前为这种情境做好准备特别有用
before the moment of crisis. One of the other ideas that you talk about that can be helpful is to name our own emotions and to potentially talk to ourselves in the third person. Talk about this idea. What do you have in mind and why would it work? So if you can't get physical distance, which is ideally the best thing, one of the things I could have done in front of Dan was to get psychological distance. And researchers such as Ethan Cross examined what happens when we talked about ourselves in the third person. So you could close your eyes and you could say, Sinita, what is it you really want to
在危机时刻到来之前。你谈到的另一个可能有用的观点是，给自己的情绪命名，并可能用第三人称对自己说话。谈谈这个想法。你心里是怎么想的，为什么它会起作用？因此，如果你无法拉开物理距离——这通常是最好的做法，我在丹面前可以做的事情之一就是拉开心理距离。伊森·克罗斯（Ethan Kross）等研究人员研究了当我们用第三人称谈论自己时会发生什么。所以你可以闭上眼睛说：“苏尼塔，你在这里真正想做的是什么
do here? And that gives us some distance to really think about what we want rather than what the other person wants for us. I understand that there has been research that finds that in fact patients are less likely to follow advice that is marred by conflicts of interest when they hear about this advice through a third party and they have some time to think about what to do. That's right. So some of my research has examined what if the disclosure is not coming directly from
做什么？”这给我们提供了一些距离，让我们真正思考我们想要什么，而不是另一个人希望我们做什么。我了解到有研究发现，事实上，当患者通过第三方听到这种建议并有一些时间考虑该怎么做时，他们不太可能遵循受利益冲突玷污的建议。没错。所以我的一些研究探讨了如果披露不是直接来自
the doctor, but it comes from a receptionist in a letter. I've even looked at giving out letters in advance, informing patients of conflicts of interest. In general, when people can deliberate on the conflict of interest disclosure, and it's simple and it's timely and it's given in advance, we do feel less trust in the advice. If you have an opportunity to change your mind in some of my experiments, that shows that's one of the most powerful things. So even though there's high compliance in front of the advisor, it drops a lot once the advisor is not in the room and you can make the decision in private or you can change your mind. And some of those results were very
医生，而是来自接待员的一封信。我甚至研究过提前发出信件，告知患者利益冲突。总的来说，当人们可以仔细考虑利益冲突的披露，而且它很简单、很及时、是提前给出的，我们确实对该建议的信任度会降低。如果你在我的某些实验中有机会改变主意，这表明这是最有力量的事情之一。因此，尽管在顾问面前的顺从度很高，但一旦顾问不在房间里，你可以私下做出决定，或者你可以改变主意，顺从度就会大大下降。其中一些结果非常
striking and shows us what we display publicly is not really our private preference. You cite an idea from the political scientist James March about three questions that people can ask of themselves when they feel like they're being pressured into doing something. What are these questions? These are three questions that James March came up with with regards to decision making in general in any situation. And the three questions are, who am I? What type of situation is this?
引人注目，并向我们展示了我们在公众面前表现出来的并不是我们真正的私人偏好。你引用了政治学家詹姆斯·马奇（James March）的一个观点，关于人们在觉得被迫做某事时可以问自己的三个问题。这些问题是什么？这是詹姆斯·马奇在任何情况下针对决策制定普遍提出的三个问题。这三个问题是：我是谁？这是一种什么情境？
And what does a person like me do in a situation like this? And I apply these three questions to situations that might require defiance. That even though we might ask these questions all the time when we're making a decision, and we often ask them implicitly, it's really good to make them explicit and think of them as some type of compass so they go around in a circle.
像我这样的人在这种情境下会怎么做？我将这三个问题应用到可能需要违抗的情境中。尽管我们在做决定时可能一直在问这些问题，而且我们经常含蓄地问它们，但把它们明确表达出来，把它们当作某种罗盘，让它们循环往复，真的是一件很好的事情。
Who am I? What type of situation is this so we can assess the situation for safety and impact? And what does a person like me do in a situation like this? What is my responsibility? And then how we act feeds back again into who you are. So talk about why asking these three questions is compelling. And I noticed that one of the questions is not what should I do in this situation,
我是谁？这是一种什么情境，以便我们评估情境的安全性和影响？像我这样的人在这种情境下会怎么做？我的责任是什么？然后我们的行动方式又会反馈到你是谁。所以，谈谈为什么问这三个问题引人入胜。我注意到其中一个问题不是“在这种情境下我应该做什么”，
but what would a person like me do in a situation like this? I find that very powerful because a lot of us have values, but we don't make them explicit. So we have values that we might say is integrity, equality, compassion, but just saying those values and not living by them day to day is often what happens. Like, there's a large gap between who we think we are and what we actually do. And that starts at a really young age. There was a survey of over 20,000 high school students that showed that nearly two-thirds
而是“像我这样的人在这种情境下会怎么做”？我觉得这很有力量，因为我们很多人都有价值观，但我们并没有明确表达出来。所以我们可能有诚实、平等、同情等价值观，但只是说出这些价值观却并没有在日常生活中践行它们，这正是经常发生的情况。比如，我们认为自己是谁与我们实际所做的事情之间存在巨大差距。这从很小的年龄就开始了。一项针对2万多名高中生的调查显示，近三分之二的
of them said that they had cheated on a test. Nearly one-third said that they had stolen something from a store in the last year. And more than 80% had said that they had lied to a parent about something significant. That breaks my heart because I have a high school student. I'm sure your high schooler is one of the 20% Sunita. But these figures are likely to be conservative. Of course, it's a sacrilegious report. One in four of them said that they had lied
他们表示自己在考试中作弊。近三分之一的人表示他们在过去一年里在商店里偷过东西。超过80%的人表示他们曾在某件重要事情上对父母撒过谎。这让我心碎，因为我有一个高中生。苏尼塔，我确信你的高中生是那20%中的一员。但这些数字可能还是保守的。当然，这是一份大逆不道的报告。他们中有四分之一的人表示他们曾撒过谎
about a question on the survey. said that they had lied about a question on the survey. And yet, you know, we say that we're happy with our ethics and integrity. So even though we rate integrity very high, we often don't live by the values that we rate. And so asking ourselves, what does a person like me do in a situation like that? We can get to our aspirational selves. If you think you are this type of person, what would I actually do in this situation? How is it that I would like to act? And this is the type of person I am.
关于调查中的一个问题。他们说自己在调查中的一个问题上撒了谎。然而，你知道，我们说我们对自己的道德和正直感到满意。因此，尽管我们对正直的评价很高，但我们往往并没有按照我们所赞赏的价值观去生活。因此，问问自己，“像我这样的人在这种情境下会怎么做？”我们可以触及我们心目中的理想自我。如果你认为自己是这种类型的人，我在这种情境下实际上会做什么？我希望如何行动？这就是我这类人的类型。
I am the type of person that would say something. There are times in our lives when defying authority and disobeying orders can be scary. We might feel psychologically scared. We might even feel physically scared. These fears can be paralyzing. In our companion episode to the story on Hidden Brain Plus, we explore how we might deal with those fears. It turns out, one of the greatest antidotes to fear is not courage, but love. If you're a subscriber, that episode should be available right now in your podcast feed. It's titled, Defeating Fear.
我是那种会说点什么的人。在我们的一生中，有时违抗权威和不服从命令可能会让人感到害怕。我们可能会感到心理上的恐惧。我们甚至可能会感到生理上的恐惧。这些恐惧可能会让人麻木。在我们在《Hidden Brain Plus》上的故事的配套节目中，我们探讨了如何应对这些恐惧。事实证明，对抗恐惧的最伟大解药不是勇气，而是爱。如果你是订阅者，那个节目现在应该可以在你的播客动态中收到了。它的标题是《战胜恐惧》。
If you're not yet a subscriber, I invite you to check out a subscription with the free 7-day trial. Go to support.hiddenbrain.org. If you're using an Apple device, go to apple.co. slash hiddenbrain. Your support doesn't just unlock great content. It unlocks a way for us to keep bringing you great content. If you're a long-time fan of the show, it's your way of showing us that you would like us to keep doing this into the future. Again, those links are apple.co slash hiddenbrain
如果你还不是订阅者，我邀请你通过7天免费试用体验订阅。访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。如果你使用的是苹果设备，请访问 apple.co 斜杠 hiddenbrain。你的支持不仅仅是解锁了精彩内容。它为我们持续为你带来精彩内容开启了一种方式。如果你是该节目的长期粉丝，这是你向我们表明你希望我们未来继续做下去的方式。再次强调，这些链接是 apple.co 斜杠 hiddenbrain
or support.hiddenbrain.org. Sunita Sa is a psychologist at Cornell University. She's the author of the book, "'Defy the Power of No in a World That Demands demands yes. Sunita thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you have follow-up questions for Sunita Sa
或 support.hiddenbrain.org。苏尼塔·萨是康奈尔大学的心理学家。她是《违抗：在一个要求服从的世界中说“不”的力量》一书的作者。苏尼塔，非常感谢你今天来到《Hidden Brain》。非常感谢。Hidden Brain由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德维克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是Hidden Brain的执行编辑。如果你对苏尼塔·萨有后续问题
and you'd be willing to share those questions with a Hidden Brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line defiance. That email address again is ideas at hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam and see you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并且愿意与Hidden Brain的听众分享这些问题，请在你的手机上录制语音备忘录并通过电子邮件发送给我们，邮箱是 ideas at hiddenbrain.org。主题行请使用 defiance。再次重复该邮箱地址是 ideas at hiddenbrain.org。我是香卡·维丹塔姆，我们回头见。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。